six one seven eight three zero 4750
let's see who else is on the phones
today let's go to the two six seven area
code caller from two six seven go ahead
oh that's you from Philadelphia and my
question to you is policing is the
biggest fall assume that Bernie does
well what do you think's in figured no
disadvantage at least I've been doing
home kind of polling around my friends
and family and I found their age needs
to be the biggest factor that people
don't want to vote for and I always
personally thought that if you got type
of primary it was time to be a lay up
plump and you have to abide it and all
those folks and it's guaranteed gonna be
great you know probably win but I'm
getting a lot of young folks and a lot
of other people older people saying that
age is the big factor why they wouldn't
vote for young and old will say Bernie's
age is why he would young and but middle
it like people in the middle there
they're okay with middle-aged like
boomers hey at a curiosity where are you
calling from criminal market little
windy out it's a wind okay wind is with
gotcha I wanted to figure out I didn't
know if you were like a nuclear sub
technician you were calling from like a
married a cage or something listen I I
don't the Bernie age thing yeah I mean
listen I'm not gonna sugarcoat it I
don't I don't know that a guy who is
he's isn't gonna be 80 years old in 2020
like no this he's not big February 79
yeah or he'd be 79 when when he would be
inaugurated I just don't know you know
I'm not a jurist in any way I just don't
know if what Democrats need to do like
I'm not talking about identity politics
it's not that bernie is a good or bad
candidate because he's a white guy I'm
just saying I don't know I'm from a
practical perspective it makes sense to
run a 79 year old white guy against what
will be a 74 or 75 year old white guy I
don't know I like I like Joe Biden as
well but he's gonna be close to 80 i I
just I'm not sure I'm not sure how do
you agree that a this biggest takeaway
factor that is big
you know in a way I do because I just
don't see other things about him that I
see as big deficit so in a sense it's
kind of like the only thing that's left
I always thought it was gonna be maybe
10 just getting past primary factor you
know put them out of it again the deans
open of that back there but yeah listen
I'm having the hardest time hearing you
it sounds really windy there and now it
seems like a band has started up I'm
gonna let you go but it's a very
important issue I'm gonna talk to it yep
I'm gonna talk about it in the future
yeah Bernie Sanders is 76 now Joe Biden
75 yep so if you're going to discount
Bernie Sanders for his age I think it
stands to reason you'd have to discount
Joe Biden I'm only a one-year difference
I agree I agree and I think both with
both of them I would just say do are
nearly 80 year old people the ones that
were going for and it's not I have no
problem with older people it's just is
that what we need or do we need energy I
don't know okay let's go to our caller
from now that they don't have energy
I've seen Bernie's jump shot by the way
and it's excellent